Get ready to be wow-ed because Disney has
really hit the ball out of the park with Beauty
and the Beast, their latest live-action take
on one of their animated classics!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Stepping into the role of Belle is Emma Watson,
who gives a lively performance that's an appealing
blend of warmth, intelligence, and independence.
Watson, of course, already has one iconic
role under her belt in the form of Hermione
in the Harry Potter movies.
But by so beautifully updating and bringing
one of Disney's premiere animated princesses
to life on the big-screen, Watson has ensured
herself another role for which she'll be fondly
remembered for many years to come.
Since making his name in Downton Abbey, Dan
Stevens has been doing a great job avoiding
posh pigeon holes by keeping his career nice
and varied.
And as the Beast, he puts in a suitably gruff
and witty turn, that's really enjoyable to
watch.
Luke Evans is phenomenal as the uber-arrogant
Gaston; in fact, he's so good it feels like
he was born to play this role, and really
he's the absolute stand-out in the cast for
me.
Like Josh Gad, who plays LeFou, Evans has
a background in musical theatre, and they
both get to put that to good use here.
However, unlike Gad, Evans hasn't really ventured
too far before into comedic territory, but
he absolutely crushes it in Beauty and the
Beast, showing he's extremely adept in the
comedy department.
As LeFou, Josh Gad, who previously gave voice
to Frozen's Olaf, works incredibly well with
Evans, adding lots of humour and lovely improvised
moments to the film.
Ian McKellen is simply perfect as Cogsworth,
and they may be smaller roles but I love Audra
McDonald as Garderobe, Stanley Tucci as Cadenza,
and Gugu Mbatha-Raw as Plumette.
Emma Thompson and Ewan McGregor have tough
acts to follow, taking on the roles of Mrs
Potts and Lumiere made famous by Angela Lansbury
and Jerry Orbach.
Both put their own spins on the role, adding
some delicious touches, and I enjoyed both
their performances, though these will still
always be Lansbury and Orbach's roles for
me.
And while I wasn't especially keen on Nathan
Mack's take on Chip in the trailers, I found
it worked much better in the actual film,
though I do still prefer Bradley Pierce's
original Chip.
Dreamgirls director Bill Condon, his co-writers
Stephen Chbosky and Evan Spiliotopoulos, and
cinematographer Tobias Schliessler have put
a delightfully fresh perspective on the classic
animation, while managing to keep alive so
much of what fans love about the original.
They've done brilliantly fleshing out many
of the characters, giving them more depth
and making their actions more believable,
as well as adding more realistic elements
to the plot and ironing out some inconsistencies
in the animated feature.
They've also included a couple of little meta
moments where the film lovingly pokes fun
at itself.
And though there's a rare moment that doesn't
feel quite as natural or smoothly executed
as the rest, for instance, when Belle meets
Lumiere, they're so few and far between they're
of no real consequence.
As for Alan Menken and Howard Ashman's genius
soundtrack from the animation, that plays
an equally prominent part in this live-action
version.
In fact, it's fantastic to hear such wonderful
new performances of those much-loved tunes,
including Be Our Guest, Gaston, Belle, and
Beauty and the Beast.
As well as making a few lyrical and musical
changes to some of the original songs, Menken
and Tim Rice have also penned three new songs,
my favourite of which is Evermore, sung by
Dan Stevens.
Speaking of the movie's song and dance numbers,
which are really charming, I've gotta give
props to choreographer Anthony Van Laast for
his work, which channels the animation's influences
including full-on Busby Berkeley as well as
adding new inspirations, such as a touch of
7 Brides for 7 Brothers.
Designer Jacqueline Durran is to be congratulated
for her work in the costume department.
And production designer Sarah Greenwood, Set
Decorator Katie Spencer, and Supervising Art
Director Niall Moroney have outdone themselves
bringing to life the world of Beauty and the
Beast, including Belle's village and the Beast's
castle.
The castle in particular is truly impressive,
with incredibly ornate interiors and exteriors
that seem to grow and subtly change over the
course of the film's two hours.
And, along with the movie's VFX team, they've
done an amazing job creating characters such
as Lumiere and Cogsworth.
The attention to detail that's gone into the
design of these characters is striking, with
elements from their human forms influencing
their look.
My absolute favourite of these is Garderobe,
who is a triumph of imagination.
To sum up: Beauty and the Beast is an enchanting
take on Disney's much-loved animated classic.
Director Bill Condon and his cast and crew
have taken what was great about the original
and built on that in new and satisfying ways,
while still including plenty of easter eggs
and nods to the original for die-hard fans.
The production design and VFX are jaw-dropping
and the costumes, cinematography and song
and dance numbers are gorgeous.
Basically, it's an absolutely magical movie
that put a huge smile on my face right from
the start yet also managed to bring a tear
to my eye.
And I cannot wait to watch it again!
Now, what are you looking forward to about
the live-action Beauty And The Beast, or if
you've seen it, what did you think of it?
Who do you think are going to be your favourite
characters and why?
Let me know in the comments below!
I've got more Beauty And The Beast videos
on the way, including cool secrets about the
making of the movie, so turn on your notifications
for Flicks And The City to make sure you catch
all my latest videos!
And if you enjoyed this video, do share it,
and subscribe for more reviews, Easter Eggs,
and crazy movie facts, some of which you can
check out by tapping or clicking the screen
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!